designing a responsive site uses the
same concepts and processes that you go
through for a non responsive site except
instead of drawing a single wide design
there are a few more to accommodate
different screen sizes I like to start
my design with the smallest form factor
usually a phone once that one's complete
I move up to the next and as each design
is completed I ask myself is there need
for a design for a wider screen at some
point there's really no need for a
bigger design by starting small
I really have to prioritize what's
important for my users what's the most
important thing that they want to do or
that they're going to see on screen when
starting big and then designing down it
can be too easy to just cut or hide
content that may be important instead by
prioritizing content and working up the
key content is always on the page and
users get the full experience no matter
what device they're using the design for
one hardware store prioritizes
information about the nearest store its
address hours and phone number and puts
those right at the top so I can find
them easily
beyond designing from small to large I
also code from small to large this way I
know that my course styles and layout
will work for any device even on legacy
browsers that don't support media
queries but probably my favorite reason
to start from small and work up is
performance by designing for the
smallest viewport first I'm forced to
think about performance from the
beginning I have to make a conscious
decision about prioritizing content and
how much data I'm sending to the user